sie erkennt hinter mir damit kommen wir
auch schon zu Verleihung des ersten
goldenen Vollpfosten 2022 in diesem Jahr
präsentiert von unserer zauberhaften
netzreporterin Larissa um vielleicht
auch mal eine junge Perspektive auf das
Jahr zu kriegen ne ja hallo ich bin
ein drin und Wahnsinn
IG hier
bei den nicht die besten ist die
schlechtesten deutschen
[Musik]
Fellatio auf unsere
Verteidigungsministerin geschrieben
sie wollte Innenministerin werden von
ganz Deutschland aber dann kam
ihr ihren Traum gestohlen was für ein
[ __ ] ja man muss immer auf seine Träume
hören das habe ich von Menderes gelernt
und schauen Sie mal wo der heute ist wer
ist bei Promi Big Brother die Arme
Christine Lamprecht aber muss seine
Arbeit machen diese gar nicht kann und
alle hatten nur sehr rum Christian
Lamprecht ist ein Sicherheitsrisiko für
Deutschland Deutschland aktuell für mich
unfähigste Ministerin meine Frau die die
Rangabzeichen nicht kann sie ist
ungeschickt sie agiert dumm erkennbar
überfordert ständig ist sie in
Stöckelschuhen unterwegs am Tag der
Invasion der Ukraine Frau aufrecht sich
hat die Fingernägel machen lassen in der
Früh
so unbeispiel der Gel Nagellack ja
rauswächst und dann ist das so ein Spalt
und das das sieht so hässlich aus ich
schwöre kennst du das nein
ich meine gut es kann ja sein dass
Christine Lambrecht neulich mal
vergessen hat rechtzeitig Munition zu
bestellen aber dafür ist sie eine gute
Mutter
wenn Sie zum Beispiel mit dem Bundeswehr
Hubschrauber an die Nordsee fliegt dann
nimmt sie ihren Sohn mit um Sprit zu
sparen dann auch wieder nur gemeckert
was sollte denn machen es gibt kaum
Ganztagsbetreuung für Kinder ich meine
sollte den jungen alleine zu Hause
lassen
das Kind ist 22 geil Vereinbarkeit von
Beruf und Familie ein Katastrophe
deswegen arbeite ich auch nicht und habe
kein Kind ja weil es geht einfach nicht
in Deutschland man muss der Realität ins
Auge fassen also
liebe Christina guck mal was ich für
dich hab den Pfosten herzlichen
Glückwunsch feier schön
ich habe vergessen wie es dazu kam
dass du plötzlich kriegst wenn es dran
warst keiner konnte ahnen was geschieht
du standst an schnell in der Kritik der
Bayer hast du doch gleich 5000 Helme
rausgerückt darum oh Frau Lambrecht du
machst uns so schön klar man findet nur
noch ganz schlecht gutes Personal für
Kampfflugzeuge ein sehr schlechter Deal
bei so viel Kohle kann das mal passieren
du bist stellst zu wenig Munition machst
zu viel Fotos von deinem Sohn wenn er
mit dir im Staat zeigene Helikopter
fliegt und darum oh Frau Lambrecht du
machst uns so schön klar man findet nur
noch ganz schlecht gutes Personal und
ich finde ganz echt dass ihr Dank dafür
gebührt denn so zeigt uns Frau Lambrecht
wohin wach
kräftemangel für
wir hauen direkt den nächsten Preis raus
und der geht dann eine Dame die
vielleicht nicht jeder gleich auf dem
Zettel hat am Ende dieses Jahres auf dem
Zettel und zwar geht er an Gloria vom
Turm und Taxi
geborene und Maria Gloria füreinander
Joachim Josephine pfefferminster Huberta
Greven von Schönburg Glauchau also für
mich ein persönliches Vorbild denn sie
hat rechtzeitig einen sehr reichen Mann
mit einem Schloss und mehreren
Privatbanken geheiratet wird das war
finde ich sehr schlau von ihr und sie
traut sich auch immer zu sagen was sie
gerade denkt selbst wenn sie gar nichts
gedacht hat
wir gehen immer mehr in Richtung moderne
DDR wobei die echte DDR viel besser war
und ähm die die haben zwar auch ein
bisschen mit zum mitgehört aber die
waren richtig toleranter als heute ja
dass das wissen viele gar nicht die DDR
hat nämlich nicht nur die Stasi erfunden
sondern auch die Toleranz
ja wirklich kann man googeln der Pfosten
ist nicht für Leute die wir gut finden
und ich fürchte die Fürstin ist gar
nicht so tolerant zum Beispiel wenn es
um Homosexualität geht oder One Love
binden bei der WM im Nahen Osten gibt es
genauso viele Schwule wie bei uns nur
das sind halt anständige Leute und die
aus religiösen Gründen hier Schlafzimmer
und ihre Sexualität etwas diskret
behandelt und wenn schon Armbinde wenn
es unbedingt sein muss dann würde ich
sagen soll derjenige die haben der
unbedingt seine tierischen Instinkte
ausleben will
oh du meine Güte die ist ja voll böse
und verrückt wird man automatisch so
wenn man altes her Oliver bitte sag es
mir du musst es doch wissen
wie war immer schon so ich sag nur der
Afrikaner Zitat schnackselt gerne daher
heute der wirklich überfällige
Lebenswerk Pfosten für ihre Durchlaucht
fürstenballa Balla und wenn man hinten
dran zieht dass das tolle dann kommt
oben der gesammelte Bullshit raus
Deutschland nicht mehr produzieren
können und das ist
herzlichen Glückwunsch schnell schnell
ein fürstliches Lied bitte schnell was
ist mit dem deutschen Adel
Blut seit 400.000 Jahren los
Mann ist stolz auf sein Geschlecht und
auf das blaue Blut doch tausend Jahre in
so Sex vor dann ihr Tribut von Storch
oder zu Gutenberg Pinkel Prinz Ernst
August ist ein Richter 13 eigentlich
wieder draußen und wäre das ein
Wettbewerb dann wer wohl ziemlich klar
ganz oben aus dem Treppchen selbst
Fürstin Gloria
wirst den Gloria von Thun und Taxis egal
was sie sagt meistens verkackt sie ist
mit verkackten meine ich es ist
unerträglich was sie von sich gibt
mittlerweile täglich bei servusreiche
Bild TV gehört sie fest zum Team
verbreite tumorvollzeug und
Verschwörungstheorien
fürs Ding glorial von Ton und Taxi egal
was sie sagt meistens verkackt dies ey
was laberst du für sing Gloria
Taxi braucht man nur um nach Haus zu
fahren
[Musik]
es muss raus meine Damen und Herren und
einen haben wir noch der letzte goldene
Vollpfosten 22 geht an Elon Musk
ja vielleicht sogar kleiner Trost denn
der arme Elon hat ja gerade erst den
Titel reichster Mann der Welt verloren
ja an den französischen Unternehmer
Bernard Arno dem gehören die Modelabel
Louis Vuitton Christian
Fendi Bulgari unter Champagnerhaus
oh mein Gott ich hasse ihn so sehr ich
habe einmal birkenstücke anprobiert mein
Körper hat sie abgestoßen doch zurück zu
unseren Preisträgern er ist reich als
Kim Kardashian und Uschi Glas zusammen
Elon Musk er hat dieses Jahr für 44
Milliarden Dollar Twitter gekauft ganz
ehrlich wie blöd kann man bitte sein ich
habe mich das schon vor Jahren
abgemeldet stell dir mal vorher Oliver
bei Twitter darf man 280 Buchstaben
schreiben so viele gibt es ganz schon
mal von mir ich habe das gesehen ja wie
soll man mit so einer dummen Seite Geld
verdienen und die Fotofilter oh du meine
Güte sie sind so schlecht fail aber ja
klar der Mann ist trotzdem ein Genie
muss man wirklich nahtlos anerkennen ich
meine der hat immer in die Rakete
erfunden und das elektrische Auto Tesla
kannst du Tesla schon mal gehört ja ein
Tesla wer ist wirklich so böse mein
Ex-Freund hat mich mit seinem zweimal
überfahren ja einmal habe ich nicht
gehört und das andere Mal war Absicht
glaube ich ja bei schlimmen trotzdem
noch weil der Charakter zählt ist ja so
ja das ist eine traurige Geschichte der
Preis allerdings geht an Elon Musk weil
unter ihm Twitter wieder deutlich mehr
hate speech zulässt bis Anfang Dezember
gab es da 58% mehr Hass gegen Schwule +
61% gegen Juden und 202% mehr gegen
schwarze also ein Irrer
Verschwörungstheoretiker und Medienmogul
der mit eigenen Raketen ins All fliegt
kurz gesagt mask ist tatsächlich ein
realer James Bond Bösewicht oh ich liebe
James Bond Filme vor allem die aus
Münster und die mit dem Schweiger die
sind lustig ja lieber Elon herzlichen
Glückwunsch zum Pfosten in der
exklusiven Ernst stavro Blofeld
gedächtnisedition und jetzt
bekommst du sogar noch einen eigenen
Wohnzimmer ab
[Musik]
zweitreichste Mensch auf der Erde
kaufte Twitter für viel zu viel Geld ist
der Dumme gefährlich will er die
Herrschaft über die Welt
seine Werbekunden bedroht er und feierte
das halbe team will auf Twitter kein
Fake News verboten mehr man darf alles
aus das geht gegen ihn
[Musik]
wir können später nach nicht gegen Putin
wollte er kämpfen ganz alleine Mann
gegen Mann dem siegerboot der die Grenze
der Ukraine an außer Tesla und SpaceX
gehört ihm ja noch in eurer Link und das
macht mir sorgen dann schraubt der Affen
einen Schipp in den Kopf die meisten
sind leider gestorben
fliegt doch endlich zum Mars
fliegt doch einfach sofort
und nimmt gleich mit an Bord
[Musik]
wissen Sie noch wie ich letztes Jahr an
genau dieser Stelle gesagt habe 2021 was
für ein drecksjahr es kann nur besser
werden
ich Vollidiot Gott waren wir naiv ja war
eine andere Zeit das einzig Positive was
man über 2022 sagen kann ist dass es
nicht mehr lange dauert da bleiben
eigentlich nur durchhalte Parolen am
besten gesungen von Friedemann Weise
[Musik]
[Applaus]
klimakleber auf der Straße
Waschlappen statt duschen gehen
dürresommer ganz Umlage streckbetrieb im
AKB jeden Tag wird alles teurer
einkaufen macht keinen Spaß
coole wird weiter verfeiert habe kauft
uns der King Gas die Zeit wird knapp
fürs Klimaziel der Haushalt in den
Miesen nur von einem haben wir zu viel
und das sind unsere Krisen
Halleluja ding dong Doppelpunkt
[Musik]
Halleluja ding dong was war das für ein
Jahr
Winnie zuverbot und Laila trotz Corona
aus dem Haus für 9 Euro bis nach Bayern
doch nicht denn der Zug fällt aus
Postfaschisten in Italien
schwappe wieder an die Macht die Queen
ist tot Gott
eine Mannschaft ohne Binde Hartz IV
heißt jetzt Bürgergeld
mangelage
zeitenwände hat das irgendwer bestellt
Halleluja ding dong und ein frohes Fest
es wird schon nicht so schlimm
auf den Rest wir hängen uns die Krisen
an den Weihnachtsbaum und lassen uns
Eisen die Tage nicht verzaubern
Halleluja ding dong vielen Dank an
Friedemann Weise
Ornella Toba und das ganze Team das war
die letzte heute schon des Jahres jetzt
kommt das ZDF Magazin Royale mit der
Innenministerkonferenz wir kehren zurück
mit einem spezialamt 20 Januar bis dahin
frohes Fest und guten Rutsch tschüss
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wir sehen uns nächstes Jahr
[Applaus]
Audi Leute ich wollte euch nur um ein
kleines Abo bitten einfach anklicken
macht's gut
na los
na los du scheiß Pferd hey